Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I got everything I need right here with me. I got air in my lungs, a few blank sheets of paper. I mean, I love waking up in the morning, not knowing what's going to happen or who I'm going to meet, where I'm going to wind up. Just the other night I was sleeping under a bridge,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我在这里拥有我所需要的一切。我有肺里的空气，还有几张空白的纸。我是说，我喜欢每天早上醒来，不知道会发生什么，不知道会遇见谁，不知道自己最终会去向何方。就在前几天晚上，我还在桥下睡觉，
and now here I am on the grandest ship in the world having champagne with you fine people. I figure life's a gift and I don't intend on wasting it. You never know what hand you're going to get dealt next. You learn to take life as it comes at you to make each day count. so that dominic was jack dawson yeah as played by leonardo dicaprio in james cameron's 1997 film titanic and you will of course remember that jack has just saved rose as played by kate winslet from jumping off the ship in a suicidal fit of depression. And his reward is to be invited up to first class from steerage to meet all the people in first class. Yeah.
而现在，我却在这艘世界上最宏伟的船上，与你们这些优秀的人一起喝着香槟。我想人生是一份礼物，我不想浪费它。你永远不知道下一张牌会发到什么。你要学会随遇而安，让每一天都有意义。多米尼克，刚才那是杰克·道森，也就是詹姆斯·卡梅隆 1997 年电影《泰坦尼克号》中莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥饰演的角色。当然，你还记得杰克刚刚从船上救下了试图跳海自杀的露丝，也就是凯特·温斯莱特饰演的角色。而他的回报就是被邀请从三等舱来到头等舱，去见头等舱的所有人。没错。
Evil Cal, the sinisterly camp fiance of Rose. Yes. And I think actually what Titanic gets really well, the film, is that steerage is actually brilliant because in due course jack will tell rose do you want to see a real party and they go down to steerage and she has a tremendous time you know there's irish dancing and jollity and fiddles and all kinds of things but actually steerage was brilliant wasn't it it was it wasn't a kind of nightmarish place of rats it was probably the best time that lots of people on this ship had ever had
邪恶的卡尔，露丝那位阴险又做作的未婚夫。是的。而且我认为《泰坦尼克号》这部电影真正做得好的一点是，它展现了三等舱其实非常棒。因为后来杰克会问露丝想不想看一场真正的派对，他们去了三等舱，她玩得非常开心。你知道，那里有爱尔兰舞蹈、欢声笑语、小提琴演奏以及各种各样的活动。但实际上，三等舱真的很棒，不是吗？它并不是一个充满老鼠的噩梦般的地方，这可能是船上许多人一生中最快乐的时光。
until obviously, you know, it all went wrong. Well, I would imagine, first of all, that a lot of people listening to this podcast will be having the best time they've ever had because they'll have just heard your Leonardo DiCaprio impersonation. Yeah, king of the world. And that, of course, is a,
直到后来，显然，一切都出了问题。嗯，首先，我想很多收听这个播客的人现在正经历着他们一生中最快乐的时光，因为他们刚刚听到了你的莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥模仿秀。没错，世界之王。当然，那是一个……
you've had to live with that comparison for years, haven't you, Tom? Well, you know, I've always been compared with Hollywood stars. Yeah, of course. But years haven't you tom well you know i'm always being compared with hollywood stars yeah of course but the difference between you is that you don't i mean you're a happily married man you didn't uh kick sadie out when she turned 25 no and if you're leonardo dicaprio you would have done yeah but jack dawson wouldn't the character of course yeah so i wasn't being leonardo dicaprio there i was being jack dawson so it's a nuanced yeah absolutely who in the long run will, of course, you know, a heroic act of self-sacrifice because he won't get on the door with Rose.
汤姆，多年来你一直不得不忍受这种比较，不是吗？嗯，你知道，我一直被拿来和好莱坞明星做比较。是的，当然。但你和他的区别在于，你不是……我是说，你是一个婚姻幸福的男人，你没有在萨迪 25 岁时就把她踢开。没有，如果你是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，你就会这么做。是的，但杰克·道森不会，当然，那个角色不会。所以我在那儿模仿的不是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，而是杰克·道森，所以这很微妙。是的，绝对是。从长远来看，他当然会做出那种英勇的自我牺牲，因为他不会和露丝一起挤在那扇门上。
Anyway, listen, we're not talking about the film yet, although we will be in due course. So just on third class. Sorry, Tom, I spiraled off there slightly in my elaborate comparison between you and Leo. So third class on the Titanic, as you rightly say, it was not just, as we will discover, the best time that a lot of these people had ever known. This is in my capacity as a white star. Propaganda. Publicity man. Yeah. But also it's the best third class in history. There's no doubt about that. All people who've written about the Titanic. Until that point, right? Yes. There have never been better third-class provisions. So what you were buying, you will be in a cabin of either two or four people.
总之，听着，我们还没谈到电影本身，尽管我们迟早会谈到的。所以，关于三等舱。抱歉，汤姆，我在你和莱昂纳多的复杂比较中稍微跑题了。所以，泰坦尼克号上的三等舱，正如你所说，正如我们将要发现的那样，这不仅仅是许多人一生中经历过的最美好的时光。这是我以白星航运公司宣传人员的身份在说话。没错。但这也是历史上最好的三等舱。这一点毫无疑问。所有写过泰坦尼克号的人都这么说。直到那时为止，对吧？是的。从来没有比这更好的三等舱设施了。所以你买到的是，你将住在一个两人或四人的客舱里。
It's very unusual to have two birth rooms in third class. It's pretty much the first time this has ever happened. Normally, they would cram people in, but you have a lot more privacy. Single women and families are put separately from couples or single men. Cabins all have wash basins. And they're ventilated, aren't they, by the fans made in Belfast? Exactly. There are showers and there are baths. Now, if you travel on a Cunard ship, often they locked the third class bathrooms, but not on Titanic So, Dominic, that's why you want to white-star it, not Cunard it, right? Correct.
在三等舱里有双人房是非常罕见的。这几乎是第一次发生这种情况。通常情况下，他们会把人挤在一起，但你在这里有更多的隐私。单身女性和家庭与情侣或单身男性是分开安置的。客舱里都有洗手盆。而且它们通风良好，不是吗？靠的是贝尔法斯特制造的风扇。没错。有淋浴间，也有浴缸。现在，如果你乘坐冠达邮轮（Cunard），他们通常会锁上三等舱的浴室，但在泰坦尼克号上却不会。所以，多米尼克，这就是为什么你想选白星而不是冠达，对吧？没错。
Correct. Though if Cunard are interested in sponsorship arrangements, they know where we are. Because white-star actually don't exist now, Tom, so this is a foolish pitch. Yeah, you're shilling for an extinct company. Yeah. So in the last episode when we did first and second class,
没错。虽然如果冠达对赞助安排感兴趣，他们知道我们在哪儿。因为白星航运现在实际上已经不存在了，汤姆，所以这是一个愚蠢的推销。是的，你在为一个已经倒闭的公司做托儿。是的。所以，在上期节目中，当我们谈到头等舱和二等舱时，
you said, well, second class have many of the same smoking room type things that they have in first class. But they have smoking rooms and bars in third class as well. They have a nice, big, airy dining saloon. And to give it a comparison, if you were traveling on a rival ship, say the Aquitania, there would be twice as many people packed into a smaller space on the Aquitaine than there would on Titanic. Well, I'm thinking of Dickens' comment when he went over first class on the first Cunard liner, and he was kind of complaining about, what is it, it'd be easier to get a giraffe into a whatever it was than to get his luggage into the cabin.
你说，二等舱拥有许多与头等舱相同的吸烟室之类的设施。但三等舱也有吸烟室和酒吧。他们有一个漂亮、宽敞、通风良好的餐厅。做一个比较，如果你乘坐的是竞争对手的船，比如阿奎塔尼亚号（Aquitania），那么在阿奎塔尼亚号上，同样的空间里挤的人数会是泰坦尼克号的两倍。嗯，我想到了狄更斯在第一次乘坐冠达邮轮头等舱时的评论，他当时在抱怨，怎么说来着，把一只长颈鹿塞进什么地方都比把他的行李塞进客舱要容易。
That's right, yeah. And so presumably these third class cabins are larger than he would have had going first class. Yeah, I would imagine so. So it is a measure of the relative degree of luxury that is being offered across all three classes. Yeah. Now, interestingly, like the other two classes, third class is not full. Again, this is an industry which is struggling with overcapacity. So there are 712, according to some accounts, third-class passengers, the majority of whom embarked at Southampton, but about 100 of them came on in France and 100 of them in Ireland. It is striking, isn't it?
没错，是的。所以大概这些三等舱比他当时住的头等舱还要大。是的，我想是这样。所以这是衡量所有三个舱位所提供的相对豪华程度的一个标准。是的。现在，有趣的是，像另外两个舱位一样，三等舱并没有坐满。同样，这是一个正处于产能过剩困境的行业。所以，根据一些说法，有 712 名三等舱乘客，其中大多数是在南安普敦登船的，但大约有 100 人是在法国登船的，还有 100 人是在爱尔兰登船的。这很引人注目，不是吗？
Because the whole reason, in a way, for building the ship and making sure that it's three inches longer than the Olympic, that this is the largest thing that has ever floated on the face of the oceans. The hyperbole is what this maiden voyage is all about. And yet still it hasn't filled. I mean, that is really striking. No, but I guess it's the assumption
因为从某种程度上说，建造这艘船并确保它比奥林匹克号长三英寸，使其成为有史以来漂浮在海洋面上最大的物体，其全部原因就在于此。这种夸张的宣传正是这次首航的全部意义所在。然而，它仍然没有坐满。我是说，这真的很引人注目。不，但我猜这是基于一种假设，
that it will fill over time. I suppose. But you'd think that it's the maiden voyage. Yeah. People would want to be a part of something so historic. They would. But why are you going... I mean, we'll come to this why are people traveling to the united states so as you said a couple of episodes ago the truth is people do not go on holiday and most people do not travel for work a very small number of people would well one person of
即它会随着时间的推移而坐满。我想是这样。但你会认为这是首航。是的。人们会想成为如此具有历史意义事件的一部分。他们会的。但你为什么要……我是说，我们会谈到这一点，为什么人们要前往美国？所以正如你几集前所说，事实是人们不会去度假，大多数人也不会为了工作而旅行。只有极少数人会，嗯，有一个人，
course who does is is may. Ismay, of course. He apparently is the person who had travelled more across the Atlantic than any other person in history. Is that right? Yeah. Okay. Amazing stat. But most people are travelling to emigrate. That's why you'd go.
当然，他确实会，那就是伊斯梅（Ismay）。伊斯梅，当然。他显然是历史上跨越大西洋次数最多的人。是这样吗？是的。好吧，惊人的统计数据。但大多数人旅行是为了移民。这就是你为什么要出发的原因。
You're not going to go to visit a friend or maybe once in a lifetime. But it's not like taking a transatlantic flight, something you would conceivably do multiple times. I think if you're going and then you have the chance to go on the largest ship that's ever been launched, you might think, oh, that'd be brilliant. I'll be part of this kind of record-breaking ship. Of course. Just striking that all three classes, they're not full. Yeah. Well, I suppose because the demand is necessarily limited. Let's talk about the people who do go, Tom.
你不会去探望朋友，或者也许一生只有一次。但这不像乘坐跨大西洋航班，那不是你可能会多次做的事情。我想如果你要去，然后你有机会乘坐有史以来下水的最大船只，你可能会想，哦，那太棒了。我将成为这艘破纪录船只的一部分。当然。只是令人惊讶的是，所有三个舱位都没有坐满。是的。好吧，我想是因为需求必然是有限的。让我们谈谈那些确实去的人，汤姆。
Of those third-class passengers, the largest number are, what did we say there were, 712. Our largest number, 118 of them are British, 113 Irish. But there are more Scandinavians in total, aren't there, than British? There are. So 104 Swedes, 55 Finns, 25 Norwegians, and 7 Danes. But then there are also groups. So 79 people from Lebanon, 33 Bulgarians, 22 Belgians, 12 Armenians, 8 Chinese, and so on and so forth. So the Chinese are apparently firemen.
在那些三等舱乘客中，人数最多的是，我们刚才说有多少来着，712 人。我们的人数最多，其中 118 人是英国人，113 人是爱尔兰人。但总的来说，斯堪的纳维亚人比英国人多，不是吗？是的。所以有 104 名瑞典人，55 名芬兰人，25 名挪威人，7 名丹麦人。但也有一些群体。所以有 79 人来自黎巴嫩，33 名保加利亚人，22 名比利时人，12 名亚美尼亚人，8 名中国人，等等。所以中国人显然是司炉工。
Yeah, by and large. So here is where we get to the immigration story. So at about this point, a million people a year are coming into the United States. So the peak, I think, was 1907, 1.125 million people. And we'll get into why people are making this choice. One reason is actually because of people I meet on paid propagandists working for White Star. So they will have agents all over the world who are producing advertisements, who are writing poems, who are painting pictures, who are doing all that about the beauties, the benefits, the bounties of the United States and how much of a better life you can have. The biggest group of Scandinavians, a lot of them are from poor rural villages. A lot of Scandinavians are very, very poor at the turn of the 20th century. So these are your classic people that you will see in...
是的，大体上是这样。所以这就是我们进入移民故事的地方。大约在这个时候，每年有一百万人进入美国。所以高峰期，我想是 1907 年，112.5 万人。我们将深入探讨为什么人们会做出这种选择。一个原因实际上是因为我遇到的人是为白星航运工作的付费宣传员。所以他们在世界各地都有代理人，他们制作广告，写诗，画画，做所有关于美国的美丽、利益、慷慨以及你能过上多么好的生活的事情。斯堪的纳维亚人中最大的群体，很多人来自贫穷的农村。在 20 世纪之交，很多斯堪的纳维亚人非常、非常贫穷。所以这些就是你在……中看到的经典人物。
In Fargo. Yeah, kind of Willa Cather novels and things. They're going to Minnesota. They're going to and things. They're going to Minnesota, they're going to the Midwest, they're going to become farmers. They're going to have very similar lives to the ones they have in Scandinavia, just much richer out on the prairies. There were remarkably few in that group. Some people may have expected there'd be a lot of people, Eastern European Jews. There are very few. And the reason, actually, is prejudice. White Star discourage Eastern Europeans from travelling from Southampton.
在《冰血暴》（Fargo）里。是的，有点像薇拉·凯瑟（Willa Cather）的小说之类的。他们要去明尼苏达州。他们要去中西部，他们要成为农民。他们将过上与在斯堪的纳维亚时非常相似的生活，只是在草原上会富裕得多。那个群体中确实很少有人。有些人可能预料会有很多人，东欧犹太人。很少。而原因实际上是偏见。白星航运不鼓励东欧人从南安普敦出发。
But they do provide kosher food, interestingly. In case they do travel. But there's a prejudice against Eastern European Jews. It is believed, and I quote, their untidiness, rudeness, and other marks of semi-civilisation make them unpopular on board. So there are a few Jewish passengers, but not that many. There are about 20 Croats. There's a guy called Nikola Lulic,
但有趣的是，他们确实提供犹太洁食。以防他们真的旅行。但对东欧犹太人存在偏见。人们认为，我引用一下，“他们的不整洁、粗鲁和其他半文明的标志使他们在船上不受欢迎。”所以有一些犹太乘客，但不多。大约有 20 名克罗地亚人。有一个叫尼古拉·卢利奇（Nikola Lulic）的人，
who is basically a chaperone, an interpreter. So often these people will travel in a group, or they will kind of club together. And one person who is experienced, this is Nikola Lulic in this case. So he's come back from America. Yes, he's crossed a couple of times. So he's learned English and he can Yes, he's crossed a couple of times. So he's
他基本上是一个监护人、翻译。所以这些人通常会成群结队地旅行，或者他们会凑在一起。而其中一个有经验的人，在这个案例中就是尼古拉·卢利奇。所以他从美国回来。是的，他跨越过几次。所以他学会了英语，他可以……是的，他跨越过几次。所以他
learned English and he can handle language and things. Poor fellow. He has been to Minnesota, like me. Because I emigrated, of course, to Minnesota, Tom, as you will recall. Yes, you did. I do remember that. Yes. 20 years ago. Actually, I wasn't really emigrating. I was going to do research. And actually, Croatian emigration to the United States is a really big thing at the turn of the 20th century. I mean, who knew that? I didn't know that. Fascinating.
学会了英语，他可以处理语言之类的事情。可怜的家伙。他去过明尼苏达州，像我一样。因为我当然移民到了明尼苏达州，汤姆，正如你所记得的那样。是的，你确实去了。我记得。是的。20 年前。其实我并不是真的移民。我是去搞研究的。而且实际上，克罗地亚人在 20 世纪之交向美国的移民是一件大事。我是说，谁知道呢？我不知道。太迷人了。
Yeah, I think it's fascinating, some of these groups. So here's a really interesting one. The Lebanese. Yeah. So all these Lebanese people in the Titanic. Well, I did know about them because there's quite a lot of pogroms going on against Christians. Right. In this area of what is the Ottoman Empire.
是的，我认为这很迷人，其中一些群体。所以这里有一个非常有趣的群体。黎巴嫩人。是的。泰坦尼克号上所有的这些黎巴嫩人。嗯，我确实知道他们，因为在奥斯曼帝国的这个地区，针对基督徒的迫害相当多。没错。
And actually in Syria as well. Exactly. So this is what's happening. And I love this side of the Titanic story, not because I love pogroms against Christians in the Ottoman Empire, but because I love the way that the Titanic operates as this window into all kinds of aspects of international life in the early 20th century. Yeah, it does. Yeah. So as you say, the Ottoman Empire is in a bit of a mess at the beginning of the 20th century. There's lots of intercommunal violence and whatnot. The people who travel to America are often Christians from Armenia or from what's now Lebanon. Richard Davenport Hines
而且在叙利亚也是如此。没错。所以这就是正在发生的事情。我喜欢泰坦尼克号故事的这一面，不是因为我喜欢奥斯曼帝国对基督徒的迫害，而是因为我喜欢泰坦尼克号作为一扇窗口，展现了 20 世纪初国际生活的方方面面。是的，确实。所以正如你所说，奥斯曼帝国在 20 世纪初有点混乱。有很多社区间的暴力等等。前往美国的人通常是来自亚美尼亚或现在的黎巴嫩的基督徒。理查德·达文波特-海恩斯（Richard Davenport Hines）
in his book, Titanic Lies, has a brilliant section on all this. There are 20 people from one particular village called Hardin, a kind of upland mountain village. Where, Tom, I'm pleased to read, there was a temple to the god Mercury, supposedly erected in the time of the Emperor Hadrian. Yeah, that's right. Who knew that Hadrian would feature in a Titanic podcast. Yeah, I'm thrilled to get him in.
在他的书《泰坦尼克号的生命》（Titanic Lives）中，有一个关于这一切的精彩章节。有 20 人来自一个叫哈丁（Hardin）的特定村庄，一个高地山村。汤姆，我很高兴读到，那里有一座据说是哈德良皇帝时期建造的墨丘利神庙。是的，没错。谁知道哈德良会出现在泰坦尼克号的播客里。是的，我很激动能把他加进来。
So these are what we would call Maronite Christians. They had previously worked cultivating mulberry trees so silk but silk prices have been falling for the last 10 or 20 years or so so they are not merely being persecuted but they are increasingly poor struggling to scratch out a living yeah and they are all going to a place called wilkes bar in pennsylvania which as american listeners will know is famous for its coal mines and they are going to a place called Wilkes Bar in Pennsylvania, which as American listeners will know, is famous for its coal mines. And they're going to become coal miners. It's nicknamed Diamond City, which makes it sound like Las Vegas. It's not like that at all. Again, good spin.
所以这些就是我们所说的马龙派基督徒。他们以前从事桑树种植，也就是丝绸，但丝绸价格在过去 10 到 20 年里一直在下跌，所以他们不仅受到迫害，而且越来越贫穷，难以维持生计。是的，他们都要去一个叫威尔克斯-巴里（Wilkes-Barre）的地方，在宾夕法尼亚州，正如美国听众所知，那里以煤矿闻名。他们要去成为煤矿工人。它被称为“钻石城”，听起来像拉斯维加斯。其实根本不是那样。同样，很好的宣传。
Very good spin. And this is part of a process that is ongoing, that minorities in the Middle East are immigrating still to this day. Yeah. Christians, Yazidis, whoever. Yeah, exactly, to the US. So there's the Lebanese guys. Then there are this group I mentioned, Armenians, 12 Armenians.
非常好的宣传。这是正在进行的过程的一部分，中东的少数群体至今仍在移民到美国。是的。基督徒、雅兹迪人，无论谁。是的，没错，去美国。所以这就是黎巴嫩人。然后是我提到的那群人，亚美尼亚人，12 名亚美尼亚人。
So these are an interesting group. They are from a particular place called the Kegi District. Again, very, very mountainous. Davenport Hines says, a place where small farmers eked out a bare existence while fending off Kurdish brigands, avaricious semi-feudal Muslim landowners, and extortionate Turkish officials. Well, and this is a terrible time. Right. Obviously, I mean, kind of midway in what will ultimately become a genocidal program against the Armenians.
所以这是一个有趣的群体。他们来自一个叫凯吉（Kegi）区的特定地方。同样，非常、非常多山。达文波特-海恩斯说，这是一个小农户在抵御库尔德强盗、贪婪的半封建穆斯林地主和敲诈勒索的土耳其官员的同时，勉强维持生存的地方。嗯，这是一个可怕的时期。没错。显然，我是说，处于最终将演变成针对亚美尼亚人的种族灭绝计划的中期。
Exactly. So this is the point at which the young Turks, the nationalist group who have seized the kind of political momentum inside the Ottoman Empire, they are pushing for a sort of what they see as a kind of modern European style Turkification of the empire and particularly of districts where Turkish speakers and let's say Armenian speakers live side by side. So tens of thousands of Armenians have already been killed by the time the Titanic sails. And in a place called like Kegi, lots of people are keen to get out.
没错。所以这就是青年土耳其党人，那个夺取了奥斯曼帝国政治势头的民族主义团体，他们正在推动一种他们认为的现代欧洲风格的帝国“土耳其化”，特别是在土耳其语使用者和亚美尼亚语使用者并存的地区。所以当泰坦尼克号起航时，成千上万的亚美尼亚人已经被杀害了。而在像凯吉这样的地方，很多人都渴望离开。
And the United States seems like the promised land. So these guys, there are 12 of them, they are coming from an extremely poor rural corner of the ottoman empire and for them third class on the titanic is unbelievable it's better than a palace you know it's like something that they've never imagined these are not people who are reading magazines about millionaire plutocrats and things their minds are blown by the public rooms by the two birth cabins by all of this kind of stuff extraordinary and there's a kind of peculiarly tragic quality about the armenians on the titanic because i mean had they stayed where they were
而美国看起来就像是应许之地。所以这些人，他们有 12 个，他们来自奥斯曼帝国一个极其贫穷的农村角落，对他们来说，泰坦尼克号上的三等舱简直令人难以置信，比宫殿还要好。你知道，这就像他们从未想象过的东西。这些人不是那种阅读关于百万富翁财阀杂志的人，他们的思想被公共房间、双人客舱、所有这些东西所震撼。非凡。而且亚美尼亚人在泰坦尼克号上有一种特别悲剧的特质，因为我是说，如果他们留在他们原来的地方，
the program of genocide is massing i mean it will will begin, what, 1915, go through to early 1920s. Yeah. You know, a million and a half killed. And they think they've escaped, but they haven't. Yeah, of course not. And all this luxury, all this relative luxury,
种族灭绝计划正在集结，我是说，它将开始于，什么，1915 年，一直持续到 20 世纪 20 年代初。是的。你知道，一百五十万人被杀。他们以为他们逃脱了，但他们没有。是的，当然没有。所有这些奢华，所有这些相对的奢华，
and then they die as well. Yeah. I mean, it's really very kind of somber quality to the irony there. Very bitter. Because these people have not generally left any written sources, it's hard to get a sense of what they were thinking. I mean, these are not people who are using the Marconi equipment
然后他们也死了。是的。我是说，这其中有一种非常阴郁的讽刺意味。非常苦涩。因为这些人通常没有留下任何书面资料，很难了解他们在想什么。我是说，这些人不是那种使用马可尼设备
to send messages and things. And also, they die. Yeah. Now, they must have noticed commonalities between all the different groups. So there's a whole kind of, it's a kind of Tower of Babel quality to it, I imagine. Lots of different groups all speaking their own language. Their experiences are probably pretty similar. So they will have been seen off with feasts and church services and things like that, or religious services.
发送信息之类的人。而且，他们死了。是的。现在，他们一定注意到了所有不同群体之间的共同点。所以我想，这有一种巴别塔的特质。许多不同的群体都在说他们自己的语言。他们的经历可能非常相似。所以他们一定是在盛宴和教堂仪式之类的活动中被送走的，或者宗教仪式。
Some of them are going to stay in America. Some of them are probably planning to come back home after a few years. Sojourning, as it's called. A lot of them are going to be remitting money back home. And there are lots of villages, so Croatia is a really good example, there are lots of villages that are increasingly dependent on remittances from people who've gone to the United States. And Greeks as well, I think, aren't there? Greeks, exactly. I think there are lots from Sparta, actually.
他们中的一些人打算留在美国。他们中的一些人可能计划几年后回家。所谓的“暂住”。他们中的很多人会把钱汇回家。有很多村庄，克罗地亚就是一个很好的例子，有很多村庄越来越依赖从去美国的人那里汇回的钱。我想希腊人也是，不是吗？希腊人，没错。我想有很多来自斯巴达的，实际上。
They are from Sparta, aren't they? When they get to America, they will move into this very kind of The Godfather Part Two. Yes. Yeah. These migrant networks. Somebody, a big guy, what do they call the padrone? A padrone will find you, work as a shoeshine boy, as a flower seller, as a... But these are the guy who speak English. Yeah.
他们来自斯巴达，不是吗？当他们到达美国时，他们会进入这种非常像《教父 2》的生活。是的。是的。这些移民网络。某个人，一个大人物，他们叫什么来着，教父（padrone）？一个教父会找到你，让你做擦鞋童、卖花童，或者……但这些人是说英语的人。是的。
Who are familiar with all the paperwork that you need and the kind of networks, shadowy networks in New York or wherever. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. These are the networks you see in all the immigrant stories and films and so on. So that's what awaits them when they get there. Before we get to the break, let's just finish off with some of the other passengers. So, of course, there are all the British and Irish families. There's one that really stuck.
他们熟悉你所需要的所有文书工作，以及在纽约或其他任何地方的阴暗网络。是的。是的，绝对是。这些就是你在所有移民故事和电影中看到的网络。所以这就是当他们到达那里时等待他们的东西。在休息之前，让我们用其他一些乘客来结束吧。所以，当然，有所有的英国和爱尔兰家庭。有一个真的让我印象深刻。
I know you said to me that this was one that stuck with you too. Oh, I know. I know. The goldsmiths. Sadie, when we went to Belfast to see the Titanic Museum and we stayed in the hotel, which was the Harlan Wolfe offices. You can stay there. It's an incredible hotel. I mean, if you're any interest in the subject, go and stay there. I'm now shilling for them. But she was reading Richard Davenport Hines' book, Titanic Lives, and came across this story. So this is, it's a family of Methodists called the Goldsmiths.
我知道你对我说过这也是一个让你印象深刻的故事。哦，我知道。我知道。戈德史密斯一家（The Goldsmiths）。萨迪，当我们去贝尔法斯特看泰坦尼克号博物馆，我们住在酒店里，那是哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂（Harlan and Wolff）的办公室。你可以住在那里。那是一家不可思议的酒店。我是说，如果你对这个主题有任何兴趣，去那里住吧。我现在在为他们做托儿。但她当时正在读理查德·达文波特-海恩斯的书《泰坦尼克号的生命》，并发现了这个故事。所以这是一个叫戈德史密斯的卫理公会家庭。
From Kent, aren't they? Near Rochester. They're from Rochester. Yeah. And so they're moving out to Detroit. And it's Frank Goldsmith, his wife, Emily, and their young son, Frankie. And they want a clean start because their youngest son had died of diphtheria in 1911. So just a few months before they get on board the Titanic. And he's interesting because he is an example of someone who gets persuaded by the
来自肯特郡，不是吗？靠近罗切斯特。他们来自罗切斯特。是的。所以他们要搬到底特律。那是弗兰克·戈德史密斯（Frank Goldsmith），他的妻子艾米丽（Emily），还有他们年幼的儿子弗兰基（Frankie）。他们想要一个新的开始，因为他们最小的儿子在 1911 年死于白喉。所以就在他们登上泰坦尼克号前几个月。他很有趣，因为他是一个被……说服的人的例子。
marketing. So he was anxious about putting his family through going on third class, but he reads up about it and thinks, actually, it's going to be fine. And he's not wrong. I mean, it is fine. And when he's going, he has a kind of family contact in America who wants his younger brother, this is a guy called Rush, and he wants his younger brother, Alfred, to come out with them. And the goldsmiths say, yes, we will take young Alfred Rush with us. Alfred Rush is 15, but he celebrates his 16th birthday on Sunday, the 15th of April, which is the last day of the Titanic. And he gets given a pair of long trousers. And the long trousers, of course, are a signifier of adulthood, of manhood. And so he puts puts them on thereby marking himself out as someone who is
营销。所以他很担心让他的家人去坐三等舱，但他读了关于它的资料，认为，实际上，这会没事的。他没想错。我是说，这确实没问题。当他去的时候，他在美国有一个家庭联系人，想要他的弟弟，这是一个叫拉什（Rush）的人，他想要他的弟弟阿尔弗雷德（Alfred）和他们一起出来。戈德史密斯一家说，是的，我们会带上年轻的阿尔弗雷德·拉什。阿尔弗雷德·拉什 15 岁，但他要在 4 月 15 日星期日庆祝他的 16 岁生日，那是泰坦尼克号的最后一天。他得到了一条长裤。而长裤，当然，是成年、男子气概的标志。所以他穿上了它们，从而标志着他是一个
no longer a child yeah and listeners will be able to imagine what the consequence of that is and the way in which this birthday present will effectively kill him yeah heartbreaking he looked young for his years tom he looked young and so this is why he was so proud of... Yeah. And the little boy is nine years old, Frankie Goldsmith. He is very excited and he's been guzzling seasickness tablets like they're sweets. So he's kind of high on seasickness tablets. Necking them furiously. And he's very excited. And he lived because we have his stories and he describes. Mummy, at last we're on the Atlantic, was his cheerful cry.
不再是孩子的人。是的，听众们将能够想象这会导致什么后果，以及这份生日礼物将如何有效地杀死他。是的，令人心碎。他看起来比实际年龄小，汤姆，他看起来很年轻。所以这就是为什么他如此自豪……是的。那个小男孩九岁，弗兰基·戈德史密斯。他非常兴奋，他一直在像吃糖果一样狂吃晕船药。所以他有点因为晕船药而兴奋。疯狂地吞咽它们。他非常兴奋。他活了下来，因为我们有他的故事，他描述道：“妈妈，我们终于在大西洋上了，”这是他欢快的呼喊。
It's actually a lovely story destroyed by that sinister impression of his. It's not sinister. No, it's full of boyish joy. And listeners will have noted the particular timbre I gave it of a boy who is high on seasickness pills. Really? Yeah. So yes, just before we go to the break. So most of these people have never been on a ship before.
这实际上是一个可爱的故事，被他那阴险的模仿给毁了。那不是阴险的。不，它充满了男孩的快乐。听众们会注意到我给它的那种音色，一个因为晕船药而兴奋的男孩。真的吗？是的。所以，是的，就在我们去休息之前。所以这些人中的大多数以前从未坐过船。
They've never seen a ship, an ocean going vessel before. And they've never had a holiday before. Lots of them. No. Because they are miners, they are farm laborers, they are stonemasons, dressmakers, servants, salesmen. They are people who do not get transatlantic liners as a matter of course. As you say, Tom, they have probably, most of them, never had a week's holiday. And they've probably, I mean, lots of them would never have had as much
他们以前从未见过船，远洋客轮。他们以前从未度过假。很多人。没有。因为他们是矿工、农场劳工、石匠、裁缝、仆人、推销员。他们是那些通常不会乘坐跨大西洋客轮的人。正如你所说，汤姆，他们可能，大多数人，从来没有度过一周的假。而且他们可能，我是说，他们中的很多人从来没有像在泰坦尼克号上那样，
food as regularly as they get on the Titanic. It is like a holiday for them. You described the DiCaprio thing and the party. They are kind of playing cards. There are people skipping. They've brought accordions. Lots of people with mouth organs. Yeah. You know, they travel with their music and they are making music. Well, you know, the research that went into that film is really good. Obviously, they take dramatic license. But it's not wrong, that portrait. And the other thing, actually, just before we go to the break,
吃得那么规律。这对他们来说就像一个假期。你描述了迪卡普里奥的事情和派对。他们有点在玩牌。有人在跳绳。他们带了手风琴。很多人带着口琴。是的。你知道，他们带着他们的音乐旅行，他们在演奏音乐。嗯，你知道，那部电影所做的研究真的很好。显然，他们采取了艺术加工。但那幅肖像并没有错。还有一件事，实际上，就在我们去休息之前，
the food which seems quite drab probably to us, they're having kind of porridge, toast and marmalade, herrings, boiled potatoes. Delicious. Love it. But to them, it's warm, filling, nutritious, and probably quite exotic because they won't have had, you know, people living in Armenia will not have had Quaker oats porridge or toast and marmalade or whatever. Or I imagine herring. I mean, they're basically living like Paddington Bear. Yeah.
食物对我们来说可能看起来很乏味，他们吃的是燕麦粥、吐司和果酱、鲱鱼、煮土豆。美味。喜欢它。但对他们来说，它是温暖的、充实的、有营养的，而且可能相当异国情调，因为他们不会有，你知道，住在亚美尼亚的人不会有桂格燕麦粥或吐司和果酱之类的东西。或者我想象中的鲱鱼。我是说，他们基本上像帕丁顿熊一样生活。是的。
And I think, you know, all the accounts we have, nobody ever who survives says. It was awful. It was so unequal and I felt so downtrodden. They think it is absolutely tremendous. So, Dominic, as an enthusiast for. Yeah, White Star. For White Star. I mean, you would say it is a great ship.
而且我认为，你知道，我们拥有的所有记录，从来没有幸存者说：“这太糟糕了。它太不平等了，我感到太受压迫了。”他们认为这绝对是太棒了。所以，多米尼克，作为一个……的爱好者。是的，白星航运。对于白星航运。我是说，你会说这是一艘伟大的船。
Yeah. It deserves all the acclamation that it gets. It does. It does. And I think it's got a very bad and cruel press over the years. For a reason that we will come to after the break. It's out on the Atlantic. What then happens? So we will be looking at the break. It's out on the Atlantic. What then happens?
是的。它值得它得到的所有赞誉。它确实。它确实。而且我认为多年来它受到了非常糟糕和残酷的媒体报道。原因我们将在休息后谈到。它在大西洋上。然后发生了什么？所以我们将看看休息。它在大西洋上。然后发生了什么？
So we will be looking at that when we come back. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
所以当我们回来时，我们将看看这一点。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are on the maiden voyage of the Titanic. And Dominic, it leaves Queenstown. Yes.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在泰坦尼克号的首航上。多米尼克，它离开了皇后镇（Queenstown）。是的。
Very near Cork, which in 1920 will be renamed Cove. Although for an English person, confusingly spelt because it's with a B-H rather than with B-E. And it steams out on the 12th of April out into the Atlantic. It is. It's following the route that all the ships in this period take. Yes. So there's nothing unusual about it.
非常靠近科克（Cork），在 1920 年它将被更名为科夫（Cove）。尽管对于一个英国人来说，拼写令人困惑，因为它是 B-H 而不是 B-E。它在 4 月 12 日驶入大西洋。是的。它遵循着这一时期所有船只采取的路线。是的。所以没有什么不寻常的。
No. Nothing unexpected. In fact, the only thing that is unusual is that the sea is very, very calm. Incredibly clement. Everything is going tremendously well. They had gone to cherbourg first then they as you say they've been to cove they picked up the last passengers they now have 1320
没有。没有什么意想不到的。事实上，唯一不寻常的是大海非常、非常平静。极其温和。一切都进行得非常顺利。他们先去了瑟堡（Cherbourg），然后正如你所说，他们去了科夫，接上了最后的乘客，他们现在有 1320 名
passengers when you add the crew that's 2235 people they have all the baggage they want yeah we haven't talked at all about the um all the mad stuff they have that they're taking as well a short story by joseph conrad ostrich plumes, a Renault car, 50,000 pounds worth of diamonds from Antwerp, a rare copy of the Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam. Tom, but they're not carrying, you mentioned the one man who's not aboard and the conspiracy theorist,
乘客，当你加上船员，那是 2235 人。他们有他们想要的所有行李。是的，我们根本没有谈论他们携带的所有疯狂的东西，约瑟夫·康拉德（Joseph Conrad）的一篇短篇小说，鸵鸟羽毛，一辆雷诺汽车，价值 5 万英镑的安特卫普钻石，一本罕见的《鲁拜集》（Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam）。汤姆，但他们没有携带，你提到了那个不在船上的人和阴谋论者，
Pierpont Morgan. He's not there because he's supervising the transfer of his art collection. Yeah. To France to escape David Lloyd George's punitive taxation. That's what he thinks anyway. He's worried that David Lloyd George is going to steal all his art. So he's not on board, but everybody else is. And as you say, everything is going tremendously.
皮尔庞特·摩根（Pierpont Morgan）。他不在那里，因为他正在监督他的艺术收藏品的转移。是的。到法国以逃避大卫·劳合·乔治（David Lloyd George）的惩罚性税收。他就是这么想的。他担心大卫·劳合·乔治会偷走他所有的艺术品。所以他不在船上，但其他人都在。正如你所说，一切都进行得非常顺利。
So Friday the 12th and Saturday the 13th, they make very good time, 500 miles on the 12th, 546 miles on the 12th and Saturday the 13th, they make very good time, 500 miles on the 12th, 546 miles on the 13th. And this is the point in the voyage where I guess, you know, Leo and Kate are carrying on, people playing cards. And they're enjoying the beautiful flat sea. So what you see in the film, you know, King of the World, all that kind of thing. It is beautiful weather. Everyone says this. They say it's not like we're at sea at all. It's a hotel. It's so calm world, all that kind of thing. Yeah. It is beautiful weather. Everyone says this. They say it's not like we're at sea at all. Yeah. It's a hotel.
所以 4 月 12 日星期五和 4 月 13 日星期六，他们取得了很好的时间，12 日 500 英里，12 日 546 英里，星期六 13 日，他们取得了很好的时间，12 日 500 英里，13 日 546 英里。这是航行中我想，你知道，莱昂和凯特在继续，人们在玩牌。他们正在享受美丽的平坦大海。所以你在电影中看到的，你知道，世界之王，所有那种事情。天气很好。每个人都这么说。他们说这根本不像在海上。它是一家酒店。它太平静了，世界之王，所有那种事情。是的。天气很好。每个人都这么说。他们说这根本不像在海上。是的。它是一家酒店。
It's so calm. All of that kind of stuff. So we get to Sunday the 14th. Now, the captain, who we haven't really talked about at all since we introduced him in the second episode. Where we had a slight disagreement, didn't we, about his nautical qualities? Yeah, you were very cruel. No, I just said that, you know that he's had three near crashes or near crashes
它太平静了。所有那种事情。所以我们到了 4 月 14 日星期日。现在，船长，自从我们在第二集介绍他以来，我们还没有真正谈论过他。我们有轻微的分歧，不是吗，关于他的航海素质？是的，你非常残酷。不，我只是说，你知道他有三次差点撞船或差点撞船的经历，
before setting out on this voyage. I'm just putting that on the record. That is the life of a captain, Tom. It's not all... No, it's not. He hadn't had any crashes at all. And then just before this voyage, he's had three. Right. Listen, we're never going to agree on this. We're never going to agree. I like a sea dog. I like a sea dog. I like a guy who with a salt and pepper nautical beard you look down on such people no i don't i like him but i you know it's very clear what's going on we've got to be honest so he you should love this thing at 10 30 that morning he leads everybody he puts on that church service a christian service tom in the first class dining saloon so that's very nice what's that him
在开始这次航行之前。我只是把那个记录在案。那是船长的生活，汤姆。这不是全部……不，不是。他根本没有发生过任何撞船事故。然后就在这次航行之前，他有了三次。好吧。听着，我们永远不会在这个问题上达成一致。我们永远不会达成一致。我喜欢海狗。我喜欢海狗。我喜欢一个有着盐和胡椒色航海胡须的家伙。你瞧不起这样的人。不，我不，我喜欢他，但我（你知道，很清楚发生了什么）。我们必须诚实。所以他，你应该喜欢这个东西，那天早上 10 点 30 分，他带领大家，他举行了那个教堂仪式，一个基督教仪式，汤姆，在头等舱餐厅。所以那很好。那是他
about those who those in peril on the sea those in peril on the sea. Those in peril on the sea. I wonder if they sung that. They do in the film, I think. Do they? Yeah, I think they do. Now, they were meant to have, interestingly, a lifeboat drill on Sunday mornings. That is standard on a White Star liner. Again, this is something that White Star do, but it's not demanded by law.
关于那些，那些在海上处于危险中的人，那些在海上处于危险中的人。那些在海上处于危险中的人。我想知道他们是否唱了那个。我想他们在电影里唱了。他们唱了吗？是的，我想他们唱了。现在，他们本应在星期天早上进行救生艇演习。那是白星航运客轮上的标准。同样，这是白星航运做的事情，但法律没有要求。
It's not required, is it? No. Yeah. English regulations don't require it. They do it out of the kindness and the concern for health and safety. Yes. For which they're famous. Health and safety gone mad.
这不是必须的，是吗？不。是的。英国法规不要求它。他们出于对他人的善意和对健康与安全的关注而这样做。是的。他们因此而闻名。健康与安全发疯了。
But it's, I mean, they say, let's have them. Captains don't tend to like to have them because they're just a massive faff and a hassle and whenever there's a big breeze which there is on that sunday morning they will take the opportunity to cancel them yes and it's starting to get a bit colder isn't it yes suddenly there's a slight icy quality to the weather oh there is yeah because that morning a lot of people are sitting out on deck chairs and things, reading and whatnot, and the kids playing on deck. But actually, after lunch, so they have their Sunday lunch, a sort of roast dinner and stuff, and they go back out. And it is a bit cold, and a lot of them retreat inside to the library. Yeah.
但这是，我是说，他们说，让我们举行吧。船长们往往不喜欢举行它们，因为它们只是一个巨大的麻烦和烦恼，每当有大风时，那个星期天早上确实有，他们会借机取消它们。是的，而且天气开始变冷了，不是吗？是的，突然天气有了一种轻微的冰冷感。哦，确实。是的，因为那天早上很多人坐在甲板椅上之类的，读书之类的，孩子们在甲板上玩耍。但实际上，午餐后，所以他们吃了他们的周日午餐，一种烤肉晚餐之类的东西，他们又出去了。而且有点冷，他们中的很多人退回到图书馆里。是的。
People are reading. They're playing cards and things. Go to the gym. Yeah, exactly. Now, one other thing that people are doing a lot of, which we haven't mentioned at all, is that we talked about technology and the obsession with speed and stuff in the early episodes. The first class passengers all have telephones. So they're ringing their stewards all the time and calling for, you know, oysters or whatever. Where's my Picasso?
人们在读书。他们在玩牌之类的。去健身房。是的，没错。现在，人们做的另一件事，我们根本没有提到，就是我们在前几集中谈到了技术和对速度的痴迷之类的东西。头等舱乘客都有电话。所以他们一直在给他们的乘务员打电话，要求，你知道，牡蛎之类的。我的毕加索在哪里？
But there is also a Marconi system on the ship. That's because you can send Marconi grams. You can indeed. So Marconi, the great radio pioneer, he has invented this machine where basically by generating radio waves and sparks and stuff, you can communicate with the outside world. And as a result of that, you have basically newspapers on the ship. They're printing newspapers. newspapers yeah so every morning they kind of put them out the atlantic daily bulletin yeah incredible there's a transmitter station at the pole do in cornwall which i've been to see that's right yes so the marconi they have a little
但船上也有马可尼系统。那是因为你可以发送马可尼电报。你确实可以。所以马可尼，伟大的无线电先驱，他发明了这个机器，基本上通过产生无线电波和火花之类的东西，你可以与外部世界交流。结果，你基本上在船上有报纸。他们在印刷报纸。报纸，是的。所以每天早上他们把它们发出来，大西洋日报（Atlantic Daily Bulletin）。是的，不可思议。在康沃尔郡的波尔杜（Poldhu）有一个发射站，我去过那里。那是对的。是的，所以马可尼，他们有一个小的
wireless station with three cabins and there are two marconi men who are marconi employees called jack phillips and harold bride who are working on the ship. And they make money for their employers for Marconi by sending passengers messages. And of course, Tom, going back to that point you made before about the capacity on the ship, because it's the maiden voyage of the Titanic, everyone is sending. People are queuing up to send messages.
无线电站，有三个舱室，有两个马可尼人，他们是马可尼员工，叫杰克·菲利普斯（Jack Phillips）和哈罗德·布莱德（Harold Bride），他们在船上工作。他们通过发送乘客信息为他们的雇主马可尼赚钱。当然，汤姆，回到你之前关于船上容量的那一点，因为这是泰坦尼克号的首航，每个人都在发送。人们排队发送信息。
I mean, it's kind of Instagram stuff, isn't it? Yeah, absolutely. Look where I am. Imagine this. You've just got a message from the Titanic and I'm in the middle of the Atlantic. That's what it is. And the apparatus breaks down on Friday night and Saturday morning. There's a huge backlog of work.
我是说，这有点像 Instagram 的东西，不是吗？是的，绝对是。看我在哪儿。想象一下。你刚刚收到一条来自泰坦尼克号的信息，我正在大西洋中部。这就是它。而且设备在周五晚上和周六早上坏了。有大量的积压工作。
So by this point, Sunday, they still have a huge backlog of Marconi messages and they are absolutely knackered. And I think that's really important in explaining what happens next. It is, isn't it? Because, of course, they're not just sending messages from the ship to dry land. They're also getting messages that have come from ships that have gone to dry land that are then being sent back out. Among these messages is the fact that the cold weather is generating iceberg action. Iceberg action, exactly. So the first inkling they had of this, and by the way, this is not that unusual.
所以到这一点，星期天，他们仍然有大量的马可尼信息积压，他们绝对累坏了。而且我认为这对于解释接下来发生的事情非常重要。是的，不是吗？因为，当然，他们不仅在从船上向旱地发送信息。他们还收到来自已经到达旱地的船只的信息，这些信息然后被发回。在这些信息中，有一个事实是寒冷的天气正在产生冰山活动。冰山活动，没错。他们得到的第一个暗示是这个，顺便说一句，这并不罕见。
So this is not something that will have people quaking in their boots and running up and down, wailing and weeping. This is standard. There's ice in the North Atlantic. But it is unusual, isn't it, that it's been quite a kind of mild winter and so quite a lot of ice has broken off. It has, yes. And you've got these great chunks that are floating around.
所以这并不是什么会让人们吓得魂飞魄散、哭天抢地的事情。这是常态。北大西洋里有冰。但确实有些反常，不是吗？因为这是一个相当温和的冬天，所以有相当多的冰块碎裂了。确实如此。而且你会有这些巨大的冰块在四处漂浮。
Yes, there's so much of it. And the icebergs are very large. So on Friday, they'd had a message from a ship called La Touraine saying there is ice, watch out, be careful. And as you say, Tom, they've had a very mild winter. There are very large blocks of ice floating south because they are so large, they take longer to melt. So they come further south and there's more of them.
是的，冰太多了。而且冰山非常大。所以周五的时候，他们收到了一艘名为“拉图兰号”（La Touraine）的船发来的消息，说有冰，要小心，要注意。正如你所说，汤姆，他们经历了一个非常温和的冬天。有非常大的冰块向南漂浮，因为它们太大了，融化需要更长的时间。所以它们漂得更远，而且数量更多。
And you get to Sunday morning and there are a couple more warnings. So there's one from a Cunarder called the Caronia and there's one from a Dutch sailor, the Noordam, saying, watch out, there's one from a cunard called the coronia and there's one from a dutch style of the nordam saying watch out there's ice and so what does captain smith do when he receives these notifications don't they well this is fascinating so we know that he saw the warning because what they are doing is they are handing over the messages on a very piecemeal basis and this is one of the criticisms that was later made, that actually if you'd seen all the warnings together and they'd been collated, you'd have said,
到了周日早上，又多了几个警告。有一个来自名为“卡罗尼亚号”（Caronia）的卡纳德邮轮，还有一个来自荷兰水手，名为“诺丹号”（Noordam），说，小心，有冰。那么当史密斯船长收到这些通知时，他做了什么呢？嗯，这很有趣，我们知道他看到了警告，因为他们处理这些信息的方式非常零散，这也是后来人们批评的一点，实际上如果你把所有的警告放在一起看，并且把它们整理出来，你会说，
oh, this is quite serious, we should watch out. But because different people are being handed the warnings every few hours in among a whole load of other messages and instructions and requests and all these kinds of things, they sort of get put down and overlooked. So Smith definitely sees the Nordam one, and then he's given another one when he's going for lunch on Sunday from a wide-style liner, actually.
哦，这相当严重，我们应该小心。但因为不同的人每隔几个小时就会在大量的其他信息、指令和请求中收到这些警告，它们就被搁置并被忽视了。所以史密斯肯定看到了“诺丹号”的那条，然后他在周日去吃午饭时，又收到了另一条来自一艘大型邮轮的警告。
Yeah, and that is the one that he gives to Ismay, isn't it? Yes. Who then kind of reads it, folds it up, puts it in his pocket, and kind of shows it to some people some of the first class passengers but nothing particularly happens no and then in the evening smith wants it back doesn't he to show to the crew but as far as we know he never actually showed it to them so i mean i know you're a big smith fan but it does seem... Well, I think here's what they're thinking. I think they're thinking, okay, there's a bit of ice,
是的，那就是他交给伊斯梅的那条，对吧？是的。伊斯梅读了读，把它折起来，放进兜里，还给一些头等舱乘客看了看，但并没有发生什么特别的事。不，然后到了晚上，史密斯想要回那条信息，不是吗？为了给船员看，但据我们所知，他从未真正给他们看过。所以，我知道你是史密斯的忠实粉丝，但这看起来……嗯，我想他们当时是这么想的。我想他们觉得，好吧，有一点冰，
but they're not thinking, you know, this is a life-threatening situation. I think they're thinking, okay, I'll make a note of that. But I suppose your excuse, if you're in the business, I mean, obviously, at some point, there's no point making excuses because they made a terrible horlicks of it and loads of people died. But if you are making excuses, you say, obviously, at some point, there's no point making excuses because they made a terrible horlicks of it and loads of people died. But if you are making excuses, you say, well, they've got loads of competing requests. I mean, they just don't take it terribly seriously, do they, Tom? Well, also, just to say, because this is obviously quite important for what's going to happen, the Titanic is built to be able to ram into an iceberg and just carry on.
但他们并没有觉得，你知道，这是一种危及生命的情况。我想他们觉得，好吧，我会记下这一点。但我想如果你是业内人士，你的借口是——我的意思是，显然，在某种程度上，找借口毫无意义，因为他们把事情搞得一团糟，导致很多人死亡。但如果你非要找借口，你会说，嗯，他们有很多相互冲突的请求。我的意思是，他们只是没有太当回事，对吧，汤姆？嗯，还要说一句，因为这对接下来要发生的事情显然非常重要，泰坦尼克号被设计成即使撞上冰山也能继续航行。
Yeah. It will not cause damage. And not just the Titanic. Like, lots of ships. Yeah, well, all of them. And so this is, I mean, I gather standard, even with icebergs, you just keep going at a steady pace. One thing to absolutely emphasise, and this is something that the film does get wrong, in which Ismay is shown urging Smith to go as fast as he possibly can so that they can reach New York before the scheduled arrival time, because it will then get the Titanic in the papers. This is not true. This did not happen. There is absolutely no evidence whatsoever that Ismay was pushing
是的。它不会造成损坏。不仅仅是泰坦尼克号。像，很多船都是这样。是的，嗯，所有的船都是。所以我的意思是，据我了解，这是常态，即使有冰山，你只要保持稳定的速度继续航行就行了。有一点必须强调，这是电影中弄错的地方，电影里显示伊斯梅敦促史密斯尽可能快地航行，以便在预定到达时间之前抵达纽约，因为这样泰坦尼克号就能上报纸。这不是真的。这并没有发生。完全没有任何证据表明伊斯梅在推动
for the Titanic to go too fast. And in fact, it was not going at full speed. No, because white star liners are not famous for their speed. The point to them is they're luxurious. I mean, Ismay in the inquiry afterwards was absolutely explicit. She said the Titanic
泰坦尼克号超速航行。事实上，它当时并没有全速前进。不，因为白星航运的邮轮并不以速度闻名。对他们来说，重点是豪华。我的意思是，伊斯梅在随后的调查中说得非常明确。他说泰坦尼克号
did not have all her boilers on. Yeah. So it's not going at an insane speed. No. Another criticism that some people made
并没有开启所有的锅炉。是的。所以它并没有以疯狂的速度航行。不。有些人提出的另一个批评
was they said, well, why didn't you really reduce your speed? Why didn't you slow down as you knew you were approaching an ice field,
是他们说，好吧，为什么你们不真正降低速度呢？为什么当你知道自己正在接近冰区时，不减速呢？
an ice zone? And the answer is not that Smith was too proud or that he was under pressure or there was this sort of, you know, hubris, Edwardian hubris. It's actually that that is not the done thing to do. A good seaman does not reduce speed going into an ice zone. That was the established procedure. You continue going as you are. And as you say, Tom, if you hit an iceberg, it is very annoying, but it's very unlikely, they think, to involve a massive loss of life. And there's an example of a ship, the Kronprinz Wilhelm, a German ship, had rammed an iceberg and crumpled its bow in 1907 and had just
一个冰区？答案并不是因为史密斯太骄傲，或者他承受着压力，或者存在某种爱德华时代的傲慢。实际上，那并不是当时的做法。一个好的海员在进入冰区时不会降低速度。那是既定的程序。你继续按原样航行。正如你所说，汤姆，如果你撞上了一座冰山，那是非常令人恼火的，但他们认为，这不太可能导致大规模的人员伤亡。有一个例子，一艘德国船“威廉皇储号”（Kronprinz Wilhelm），在1907年撞上了一座冰山，船头撞瘪了，但它只是
carried on merrily to port. But just one consideration that might perhaps have given Smith pause for thought is the fact that, so we're now the night of Sunday, the 14th of April, and it's the fifth night of the voyage, and the conditions are unbelievably calm so it's a very very flat sea absolutely clear sky blaze of stars and because the conditions are so flat that means it is actually very difficult to spot icebergs because there is no swell yeah giving away their presence yeah i think that is really important because they don't see it until the last possibly that might have been a consideration yeah so as you say we get to sunday evening it's very cold and everybody's gone
愉快地继续航行到了港口。但有一个考虑因素可能让史密斯犹豫了一下，那就是，现在是4月14日周日的晚上，这是航行的第五个晚上，条件平静得令人难以置信，海面非常非常平坦，天空绝对晴朗，繁星闪烁。因为海面如此平坦，实际上很难发现冰山，因为没有涌浪来显示它们的存在。是的，我认为这非常重要，因为他们直到最后一刻才看到它，这可能是一个考虑因素。是的，所以正如你所说，到了周日晚上，天气非常冷，大家都进去了。
indoors now some listeners may remember our podcast which we talked about tom brown's school days i'm delighted to say that the author of that book thomas hughes makes an indirect appearance here because his son-in-law is on the Titanic, the Reverend Ernest Carter. So he's a vicar. Well, you would be a vicar if you were a great devotee of Tom Brown's school days, wouldn't you? Yeah, I think you probably would, yeah. Dr. Arnold and all that stuff. Yeah.
现在，一些听众可能还记得我们谈论《汤姆·布朗的学生时代》的播客。我很高兴地说，那本书的作者托马斯·休斯在这里间接露面了，因为他的女婿就在泰坦尼克号上，即欧内斯特·卡特牧师。所以他是一位牧师。嗯，如果你是《汤姆·布朗的学生时代》的忠实拥趸，你当然会成为一名牧师，不是吗？是的，我想你可能会，是的。阿诺德博士和所有那些东西。是的。
So he has a hymn singing service in the second class cabins. It's like a Rest Is History live show, Tom. He asks people, what hymns would you like? And they shout out hymns and he's able to tell them who wrote the hymn the history behind its composition
所以他在二等舱举行了一场唱赞美诗的仪式。这就像是《历史就是这样》的现场秀，汤姆。他问人们，你们想唱什么赞美诗？他们大声喊出赞美诗的名字，他就能告诉他们是谁写的这首赞美诗，以及它创作背后的历史。
brilliant I mean if you have to have a last night yeah that's the kind of entertainment you want definitely
太棒了。我的意思是，如果你必须度过最后一个夜晚，是的，这就是你想要的娱乐方式，绝对是。
oh definitely that would be your last thought as you died of hypothermia at least I had a brilliant night with hymns what a wonderful night of hymn history
哦，绝对是。当你死于体温过低时，那将是你最后的想法：至少我度过了一个美妙的赞美诗之夜，多么美妙的赞美诗历史之夜。
yeah so yeah people are singing people are playing cards hypothermia at least i had a brilliant night with him what a wonderful night of him history um yeah so yeah people are singing people playing cards people are just quietly reading all of that sort of stuff and everyone is i mean those who survive do remember it as being a brilliant evening so a young jack thayer who is only 17 yeah i went onto the boat deck it was deserted and only the wind whistled through the stays and blackish smoke poured out of the three forward funnels because actually the four tunnels we should say the fourth one is a is a fake yes for symmetry yeah it was the kind of a night that made one feel glad to be alive oh that's very poignant tom because they are getting more messages now 7 30 a message from the lane in lines california 9 40 a message from the steamship Masaba.
是的，所以人们在唱歌，人们在打牌，人们只是安静地阅读所有这些东西，每个人都是——我的意思是，那些幸存下来的人确实记得那是一个辉煌的夜晚。所以年轻的杰克·塞耶，他只有17岁，是的，他走到船甲板上，那里空无一人，只有风在支索间呼啸，黑色的烟雾从前方的三个烟囱中喷涌而出，因为实际上——我们应该说，第四个烟囱是假的，是的，为了对称，是的。那是一个让人感到活着真好的夜晚。哦，那太令人心酸了，汤姆，因为他们现在收到了更多的信息：7点30分，来自加州人号（Californian）的信息；9点40分，来自马萨巴号（Masaba）蒸汽船的信息。
And a lot of these messages, you know, are just being dumped on a table in the bridge. Because they're all tired and overworked and it's a Sunday evening. Yes, exactly. And actually those later messages, those officers who survived said, well, I didn't see them. I remember vaguely seeing as somebody had put a piece of paper with the word ICE down on the notice board or on the table, but I don't really recall a conversation about it.
而且这些信息中的很多，你知道，只是被扔在驾驶台的桌子上。因为他们都很累，工作过度，而且这是一个周日的晚上。是的，完全正确。事实上，那些幸存下来的军官说，嗯，我没看到它们。我模糊地记得看到有人把一张写着“冰”字的纸放在公告板或桌子上，但我真的不记得关于它的谈话。
So Captain Smith, meanwhile, is dining with the Widners, isn't he? He is. So the young bibliophile, his dad. That's right. And that's not negligence on his part. I mean, that's expected of the captain. That is demanded. It is, because making sure that the wealthiest passengers are happy is a crucial part of his job so the person who effectively
与此同时，史密斯船长正在和威德纳一家共进晚餐，不是吗？是的。那个年轻的藏书家，还有他的父亲。没错。这并不是他的疏忽。我的意思是，这是对船长的期望。这是必须的。是的，因为确保最富有的乘客感到满意是他工作的重要组成部分。所以实际上负责这艘船的人，当值的军官是一个叫威廉·默多克的人，他接替了查尔斯·莱托勒的班。他来自苏格兰。他是一位非常有能力的军官。认识他的人形容他精明可靠。我想他39岁，刚过40岁生日。他是大副。所以他是一个经验丰富的人。他没有得到史密斯的授权去降低速度，尽管船已经进入了一个有冰山的区域。所以他没有减速。船继续航行，以22节的速度前进。幸存下来的莱托勒记得当时漆黑一片，冷得要命，天空没有一丝云彩，海面像玻璃一样。他再次说，你知道，他也是一位经验丰富的军官，他从未见过如此清晰的条件。
is in charge of the ship the officer in watch is a man called william murdoch who has replaced the junior officer to him charles lightoller on watch he is from sc Scotland. He's a very competent officer. He is described by someone who knew him as being canny and dependable. He's 39, I think, so just before his 40th birthday. And he's the first officer. So he's a man of great experience. He has no authority from Smith to reduce speed, even though the ship has entered a zone where there are icebergs. And so he doesn't. The ship plows on, it's making 22 knots, and Lightoller, who survives, remembers it was pitch dark and dead cold, not a cloud in the sky, and the sea like glass. And again, he says, you know, he's an experienced officer as well, he had never seen such clear
所以这对接下来要发生的事情意义重大。这些条件可能会让人觉得，嗯，看到冰山一定很容易，但正如你所说，这就是它如此重要的全部原因，它真的很难看到。现在有六名瞭望员，两个在瞭望塔上，一个叫李，一个叫弗雷德里克·弗利特。弗雷德里克·弗利特是一个有趣的人。他20出头。他是一个弃儿。
conditions. So this is incredibly significant for what is going to happen these conditions might make people think well it must be easy to see an iceberg but as you say it's it's i mean that's the whole reason why it's so significant it's really hard to see now there are six lookouts there are two in the crow's nest a guy called lee and a guy called frederick called Frederick Fleet. Frederick Fleet is an interesting person. He's in his early 20s. He's a foundling.
他婴儿时被母亲遗弃，在巴纳多博士的孤儿院里长大。他12岁就出海当了甲板工。正如你所说，他正在瞭望塔上观察。当然，在电影里，他被莱昂纳多和凯特分散了注意力。当然。是的。所以大约是11点半，他正在观察。因为海面太平静了，他没有看到你预期的冰山底部的那种浪花。
He'd been abandoned by his mother as a baby and raised in a Dr. Bernardo's orphanage. And he had gone to sea at the age of 12 and become a deck boy. And as you say, he's looking out from the crow's nest. Although in the film, of course, he's distracted by Leo and Kate. Of course. Yeah. So it's about half past 11 and he's, you know, looking out. And because it's so calm, he doesn't see the sort of the surf that you would expect at the base of an iceberg.
是的。那本可以警告冰山即将来临。在晚上11点40分，他看到前方航道上有一个黑影。他按了三次铃，大喊“正前方有物体”。他给驾驶台打电话说，“正前方有冰山”。这传到了负责的默多克那里。然后他犯了一个致命的错误。我的意思是，大多数人会说他应该直接撞上去，正面撞击。
Yeah. Which would warn that an iceberg was coming. And at 11.40pm, he sees a dark shape right ahead in the ship's path. And he rings the bell three times, object dead ahead. And he telephones the bridge and he says, iceberg right ahead. And this is getting through to Murdoch, who's in charge. And he then makes a fatal mistake. I mean, most people would say he should have just gone straight ahead, gone straight for it, rammed it head on.
但在某种程度上可以理解，也许是本能。谁知道呢？或者也许他认为他能避开它。嗯，我想他差点就避开了。是的。你知道，这不是一个极其糟糕的决定。所以他下令向右满舵，并倒转引擎，试图绕过它，利用推力后退并转向。所以他试图把船头转向左舷，
But understandably, in some ways, maybe it's instinct. Who knows? Or maybe he thought he could clear it. Well, he almost does clear it, I suppose. Yeah. You know, it's not a ludicrously bad call so he he orders it to turn to starboard yeah and to reverse the engines yeah to swing around it so to get thrust to pull back to swing round yeah so he's trying to swing the ship's bow to port
这样它就能避开冰山。任何看过电影的人都知道，这很精彩。即使你知道会发生什么，你仍然能感受到那种紧张感。但船的速度太快了，无法奏效。船的一侧撞上了冰山粗糙的边缘。冰山就像一个开罐器，撕开了船的一侧。但当然，他们都不知道这一点，对吧？
so that it will miss the iceberg and anyone who's again seen again, seen the film, I mean, it's brilliant. Even though you know what's going to happen, you still feel the tension of it. But the ship is going too fast for it to work. And the side of the ship runs up against the rough edge of the iceberg. And the iceberg, it's like a kind of tin can opener shredding the side of the ship but of
在下一集中，当我们谈论它产生的影响时，我们将讨论人们的反应，他们认为自己听到了什么，然后看到了什么，以及他们做了什么。但也许我们应该以这个场景结束，它让你感受到那一刻的不确定性。所以他们试图绕过冰山。他们以为他们做到了，只是擦了一下，对吧？是的，所以弗利特在那种疯狂中，他认为一切都好。
course none of them know that do they in the next episode when we talk about the effect that that has we'll talk about the reactions that people have what they think they hear what they then see and what they do but maybe we should just end with this one scene which gives you a sense of the uncertainty at that moment. So they're trying to go around the iceberg. They think they've done it, and they've just kind of scuffed it, haven't they? Yeah, so Fleet in the craziness, I mean, he thinks that all is good. Yeah.
一切都很好。我想他并不孤单。很多人认为他们刚刚避开了它。但有一个叫詹姆斯·威特的乘务员，他在二等舱吸烟室，他谈到那个最后的夜晚时说，那是一个美丽、晴朗但非常寒冷的夜晚，海面像一面玻璃。汤姆，你又来了。当我在午夜关门前清理二等舱吸烟室时，一切都很安静。他描述了当时的场景，大约有40人在那里。通常周日不允许打牌，但规则已经放宽了，因为这是处女航。所以有三组人在打牌，他只是安静地清理他们周围的杯子之类的东西。然后他说，突然间，船身轻微震动了一下，然后一切似乎都恢复了正常。问题是，在那间二等舱吸烟室里打牌的40个人中，四小时内，十分之九的人都会死亡。
All is fine. And he's not alone, I think. A lot of people think they have just veered past it. But there was a guy who was a steward called James Witter, and he was in the second-class smoking smoking room and he says of that last evening it was a beautiful clear but very cold evening the sea was like a sheet of glass there you go again tom while i was clearing up the second class smoke room ready for closing at midnight all was very quiet he describes the scene there are about 40 people there normally they're not allowed to play cards on sundays but the rule
所以，在下一集中，我们将描述在那次与冰山的灾难性碰撞之后发生的事件，
has been relaxed because it's the maiden voyage so the three groups of them playing cards and he's just quietly clearing up the glasses and stuff around them and then he says suddenly there was a jar the ship shuddered slightly and then everything seemed normal And the thing is that of the 40 men who were there in that room, in that second classroom playing cards, within four hours, nine out of 10 of them would be dead. Right. So in our next episode, we will describe the events that follow on that disastrous brush against the iceberg
以及最终导致泰坦尼克号沉没和船上大量人员死亡的过程。所以如果你想听，你可以直接去therestishistory.com收听。如果没有，它很快就会发布。所以我们到时见，那将是非常戏剧性但非常痛苦的一集。再见。再见。
and the process which culminates in the sinking of the Titanic and the death of huge numbers of the people on board that ship. So if you want to hear that, you can hear it straight away by going to the rest is history.com. If not, it will be going out very soon. So we will see you then for what will be a very dramatic but very traumatic episode. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是这样》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并优先获得现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您想收听无广告内容、获取额外剧集并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。